humans have been drinking it for
millennia wholesome healthy bulking milk
but this dairy in Beijing isn't quite
what it seems these cows have all been
genetically modified and this is human
breast milk the Chinese scientists
responsible successfully inserted the
human breast milk gene into a cow embryo
and then implanted it into a surrogate
the result is a transgenic herd of 300
and look the scientists claim is
healthier than the following variety the
human breast milk produced by the cows
is antibacterial and helps boost the
immune system with government approval
it could be on supermarket shelves
within three years you may find the idea
hard to swallow your years I'm sorry but
these dairy workers disagree got a penny
you know that they say it's stronger and
sweeter than cow's milk
it's a world-first in a country that's
leading the stampede to embrace
genetically modified food the scientists
who created this herd have also produced
animals that are resistant to mad cow
disease as well as beef cattle that are
genetically modified for more nutritious
meat critics say the risks of transgenic
food aren't yet fully understood but
while the West's worries about the
dangers and morality of genetic
modification are China says those
scruples are misplaced your secure ll
you mean your soui there are one and a
half billion people in the world don't
have enough to eat it's our duty to
develop science and technology not to
hold it oh and we engaging we need to
feed people first before we consider
ideals and convictions choose your heart
center moving China's pushing the
boundaries of genetic modification
seemingly unperturbed by any ethical
concern
Polly Williams Sky News Beijing
[Music]